the goalposts shift swell states all
across the country are getting antsy
Americans want to get back to work and
the governors in states that have
largely controlled the outbreak or we
didn't see much of an outbreak at all
are making plans to just do that
well Texas for example released a
rolling timeline for lifting coronavirus
restrictions on April 20th they're
reopening state parks on April 22nd
removing some restrictions on elective
surgeries on April 24th retail stores
can start offering to go services on
April 27th the governor will unveil more
details on opening businesses like
theaters and restaurants joining me now
is Dan Patrick lieutenant governor of
Texas and also Marty Davis president and
CEO of Minnesota's Cambria lieutenant
governor let's start with you critics
are saying that you all have the 10th
highest number of cases in the country
so why are you ready to get this
reopening thing going well because we're
watching Laura the hospitalizations
we're watching the death rate I don't
know if I'm exact on this number but I
think we're the lowest per capita deaths
in the world possibility we have 29
million citizens and we've had 14 of 417
deaths as of earlier today so our
citizens are doing it right what we've
done is working out of 29 million people
and every life is precious and valuable
we don't diminish that but Texans are
ready to get back at work and today I
join the governor of the press
conference and we're rolling out slowly
smartly and safely but we need to get
back to work we can do two things at
once America is ready to get back Texans
are ready to get back and we're leading
the way Marty Minnesota is a very
interesting state for a lot of reasons I
love Minnesota but you comparatively you
have few Cova deaths thankfully they
have been able to control this pretty
well
yet you have a pretty serious lockdown
in place been somewhat relaxed with golf
course as I understand today that's nice
that's going to be opening but people
are protesting at the governor's mansion
they're saying or done with this
shutdown
they were out there and Trump's tweeting
liber8 Minnesota Marty what's going on
well I think there's a lot in the air
and it's moving fast we went out on
shelter in house on the 27th so we've
been out 21 days our governor has done a
really a good job in in the last 21 days
to stuart and navigate our state I think
what cause it's getting lengthy to
consider staying out longer it was
extended to May the 4th and so people
are getting very restless we need to get
the businesses and kids back to school
the businesses back to work to be sure
our I think what alarmed Minnesota was
the the regional partnership that was
created a couple days ago a day ago with
Michigan and Ohio and Kentucky in
Indiana
in Wisconsin and I really think that
that that through an alarm George
Minnesota citizens our governor I think
has corrected that or maybe not correct
that if we clarified it for its Laura
and that well they're going to have a
learning exchange and a collaboration at
that level that in fact our governor is
going to govern the state independently
with reality on the ground here in
Minnesota and he proved that today by
opening up golf courses opening up the
lakes fishing it's a big area for
Minnesota for that aspect as well as he
opened up now sails with with takeout
and he just signed that bill an hour ago
so I'm I've actually passed ik that he
is he is going to turn the corner on
this thing people are getting restless
yeah Dan people are getting restless you
see it Huntington Beach California
they've got people at Huntington Beach
he had the Michigan protests you have
the Pennsylvania State Senate saying no
to the governor's you know very
draconian shutdown there and you just
get the some people if people are want
want the elderly especially the
vulnerable to be protected they want
maybe new protocols for a while but Dan
there's a lot of people concerned that
the new normal they say we have to live
in is what basically what they've always
wanted they want fewer cars they want
they will you know they don't like this
idea of necessarily all they these
Texans in the football stadium all the
time I mean there's a lot of people
worried that the
way of life is just gonna go along with
this virus well we will get back I
believe with the president's lead and
and with the private sector finding a
vaccine at some point we will get back
to life as it was but we're starting now
to begin that process and Laura I will
tell you what people are really getting
upset with and that's the Democrats in
Congress not showing up to do their job
we need the PPP program you know Laura
I'm a small business person business is
needed we're out of money in that fund
if I were the Republicans I would show
up every day in the Senate and the house
and sit at your desk and say we're here
to do the people's business and secondly
Laura you know I'm really tired of Nancy
Pelosi and Congress because they're you
know what they're not hurt by this Laura
they make one hundred and seventy four
thousand dollars a year they haven't had
their pay cut they're at home they're
doing nothing it's time for them to get
back to work and quite frankly I think
they need to take a half pay cut and I
can speak to that clearly Laura because
in Texas we make our senators and our
House members and myself make six
hundred dollars a month we work 50 hours
a week we have the tenth largest economy
we meet every year we're volunteer
public servants it's time for Congress
to take a pay cut so they feel some of
this pain that people at home are
feeling because Congress isn't feeling
any pain the people and the small
businesses are get back to work and cut
your pay and show that you're with us
yeah absolutely get back and we get back
to work I've been saying this for a
month where's Congress I've been for all
months I've been saying they're a yeah
the Statehouse is all across this
country and and Congress should have had
their butts in their offices doing the
work of the American people it's wartime
Marty really quickly really quickly you
have a lot of workers you have 900
workers at your plant and in Minnesota
to give me an example of how this is
affecting the average world I'll give
you a good example of what the
lieutenant governor just said I had an
employee call me from LA after the mayor
put the policies in two days ago and she
said Marty I'm no longer concerned about
losing my life to the virus I'm
concerned about losing the life I built
to the lockdown and the restrictions and
she says she's a working mother with a
thirteen year old and a two-year-old
who's worked her ass off for 22 years to
try to build something up and now she's
losing her
she's under financial security she's
losing a lot of the viability of her
career and her future forward
financially and that really is what's
driving these people in the streets I
think yeah I think it's just they want
to feel they they want to save their
lives
I mean mothers fathers small business
owners you know we're all you know we're
all in this together as Americans we
want to protect and save lives but we
want to save our way of life I've never
liked the phrase the new normal I've
never liked that phrase because it
portends something different coming down
the road long after this virus is gone
and Laura all gap will have compassion
for the sick here absolutely that's a
dirty pool to say that somebody that
wants to get back to work doesn't
compare care care about the afflicted
that's that's absurdity I know Dan cares
about his state and Greg Abbott and I
hope every governor and mayor has the
same same goals in the end it shouldn't
be political gentlemen thank you so much
great to see both of you two different